our next story here Florida's Matt gates
to introduce a bill to funding Jack
Smith investigation targeting Trump we
must act so there's a bit of a follow-up
on a story we told I believe two days
ago where Trump is insisting that he's
going to be arrested at some point
because of this investigation but
representative Matt Gates announced
Tuesday he would be introducing
legislation in the House of
Representatives to defund special
counsel Jack Smith's grand jury
investigation into the January 6th
Capital Riot and efforts to overturn the
2020 presidential election I will be
introducing legislation to defund Jack
Smith's Witch Hunt against President
Trump Gates wrote on Twitter just hours
after former president Donald Trump
confirmed on social media that he had
been notified he was the Target in an
investigation and expected to face an
arrest and indictment they are attacking
our democracy and engaging in election
interference right now the United States
Congress has the capacity to stop this
election interference and we must act
immediately Gates added so how do you
guys feel about this are you happy with
with what Gates is doing here do you
think this is the proper strategy to
prevent something like this to occur
does he have any other choice and what
do you think is going to come of the
investigation into Donald Trump we know
they've been desperately trying to nail
him on anything is this what they're
going to finally be able to cook up some
trumped up charges on well Smith's been
trying to get the trial moved
aggressively to December which would put
him right at the heart of the beginning
of the primary season debates and people
say well okay there's no statute of
limitation on this quote-unquote crime
so we don't have to do it and you know
we don't have to do it in December we
could do it in 2026 what's the rush to
have it done now and the rush clearly is
to interfere with the election so I
don't think Congress has any other
options right the other options are
sadly the riots but I don't want that to
happen right I don't want to see America
devolve into chaos but there are the
mega movement is big and they're not
going to be quiet about it and so I
think it's the first step of hopefully
de-escalating what is otherwise an abuse
of of the doj it's a clear violation or
it's a clear interference in the
election right and for the Biden
Administration to say whoa hey look this
is just the doj acting autonomously and
independently and we have no common
Korean Jean Pierre is constantly saying
I have you know asked them about it
um I I think I think if this were
happening in the Congo we would laugh at
it right when this happens in Russia and
Vladimir Putin's opponents all suddenly
disappear right um or get arrested we
laugh at it and so I I applaud them
taking some action legally and they have
the power of the person so this is their
jurisdiction and I think we should see
more of it yeah when I was reading the
story today I guess I hadn't totally put
together that uh Smith is responsible
not just for the January 6 investigation
but he's also the one leading the probe
into the uh classified documents issue
that led to the the raid on Mar-A-Lago
you know Trump just pled last month not
guilty to 37 charges to the
investigation I can't help but feel like
there's some kind of conflict that this
guy who's already leading an
investigation that is going to trial was
like great great so now they've got
those charged under we're starting
another one here we go that seems like
complete conflict of interest like why
would we continue to to fund money
towards this person exactly like what
you're saying when it seems like there
is a clear uh timeline issue you have to
question intent when someone who could
bring these try bring these charges
later is like no but we have to do them
now yeah and also now that I have some
charges on table I want more exactly you
know he's not going to open up a third
investor like this is going to go on
they're going to do this all day long
and so this is from uh gates.house.gov
the power of the purse is not some
intermittent thing that we wield every
fiscal cycle it's something that we have
to wield in day in and day out to
achieve victory for our people and stop
this I'm under No Illusion that the
Democrats will bring such legislation up
in the Senate but the American people
deserve to know where Congress members
stand I I think that's exactly right I
think that's completely fair I think
that something does have to be done
about this and you're right the timing
of this investigation is more than a
little suspicious the idea that well
this is the doj and they just have no
common interest look the Department of
Justice said after Roe was overturned
that they were going to essentially
dishonor what the court wanted they were
going to make sure that these uh
procedures were as protected as they
possibly could be they were also going
to increase their vigilency against the
violations of the face act and what that
ended up resulting in was trumped up
charges against Mark Houck the idea that
the left-wing political apparatus isn't
collaborating with itself because it has
so much respect for the idea of checks
and balances within United States
government when these people repeatedly
Say by any means necessary and that
they're interested in the process and
not the results isn't just hopelessly
naive it's actually cynical these people
know what they're doing they know why
they're saying the things that they're
saying and they're exploiting the
American people's good faith I remember
back in 16 when there were all the uh
Trump Clinton things breaking and there
was russiagate right in the pp tape and
all that and you always saw the name you
saw the name Peter stroke and then there
was Hillary Clinton the 33 000 emails
and you saw the named Peter stroke I
remember thinking does anyone else work
at the doj right like how come this one
guy yeah and that's what I think of with
Jack Smith now it's like everything is
his case like doesn't the doj have 40
000 people who work there how come this
one guy seems to be getting all the
pictures talking to Trump right now how
come he never goes to his supervisor and
can I just have something else off my
plate I'm really busy these days it's
very funny how the same people get all
of these cases I'm sure it's just a
coincidence it's just a coincidence that
he's probably not definitely being like
okay but what's the next thing I can
bring again
not suspicious to people that the man is
continually investigated by people who
hate him in every investigation up until
this point has shown that he was
innocent that he was not guilty the
thing that they were alleging and they
just keep launching new investigations
into him and we're supposed to believe
it's not politically motivated it's
insane and I think there are a lot of
cases of this right now where you know
with this case it's the OJ but there are
a lot of attorney generals and Trump has
experienced this with Leticia James in
New York who will say I we think you did
something wrong give us all your private
information and confidential data and
we'll go through it and then we'll
decide what charges we're bringing
against you just as the founders
intended just as without as intended
this is this is the America they
promised me right where you can do so
under investigation you are subject to
subpoena you have to comply or else be
brought up on some other kind of charges
unless they decide they like you right
like this is completely about political
favoritism it's not about Justice it's
not about accepting that some people
have different values found a bag of
cocaine at the White House we don't know
like who cares could be anybody's yeah
George Washington left that thing no
idea exactly and like it could be
anybody's yeah let's find out who that
makes it scarier it could be anyone at
the White House it's bag of coke who's
doing this and shouldn't we be concerned
that the Secret Service who's tasked
with protecting the president can't tell
you where that case
them look terrible terrible and instead
they're just like okay well that's over
we don't know funny though as that was
coming out I know it's evolving but I
had been in the West Wing a number of
times when I was in the Bush
Administration and and at first they
made it sound like it was in this public
door that everyone walks through and she
kept saying crazy jump here kept saying
it's a highly trafficked area and then
they narrowed it narrowed it and then
when they finally confirmed where it was
you say like you can't go I couldn't go
down there right no one can go she meant
drug traffic
so it's so funny and you can narrow the
scope of who has access to that room in
there it's actually a hunter Biden every
hole that's what the door is it's the
only thing it's hard to say like the
god-shaped hole I have in my heart
shaped hole in the White House no it's
just wildly just hysterical and again I
think that the Biden Administration
should be embarrassed that they're
sacrificing the Secret Service like
you're you're saying as the president
you're not concerned that the people
tasks are protecting you can't figure
out where that came from or else the
obvious you know what I mean it's the
same as the scotus leaker right yeah it
could be don't go after him well okay it
could be anybody but how many people see
the the unredacted draft version of
documents right everyone do you it's
like well we know so everyone sees that
everyone everyone know what the Supreme
Court is doing so we know it's this
chord now let's get going right so they
make it sound like like why do you why
do you treat us like children just stop
pretending that we're dumb the American
people I know I just called them dumb
perverts when that's sad but but for the
most part of the American people are not
that stupid well they lie we know that
they're lying they know that we know
that they're lying we know that they
know that we know that they know that
they're like
this I think that was Soulja nitskin
yeah oh yes yes
they continue to I think I think on some
level it's it it almost comes across as
a humiliation which like come on this is
what you're going with you don't know
who belong to you're not going to
investigate that
um also I mean you just see how
diametrically opposed the situation is
with Trump uh and Joe Biden are those
two situations respectively Trump has
had every single element of his life
turned upside down and had a flashlight
shown on it and we have not found any
illegal accidents so he might be the
least innocent person ever I know and
this is the thing when he first ran I
liked him because of who his enemies
were and he grew on me but I wasn't
gonna say I know that this guy's
innocent I know these investigations are
phony when the Russia gate stuff first
came out and they made these nonsense I
went maybe I have no idea let's see but
then as time went on and I think I just
assumed because he was running for
office that he had legal skeletons in
his closet because that seems to be a
require environment in the United States
right but as time went on and they kept
launching these investigations I went oh
my goodness this guy's amazing squeaky
clean this guy is squeaky clean now with
Hunter Biden and Joe Biden we literally
have whistleblowers at the IRS coming
forward two of them at once to say that
the investigation into Hunter was slow
walked and that every effort was made to
ensure that they weren't going to find
anything and they weren't going to give
them a conviction we had Marjorie Taylor
green yesterday at the house basically
speaking with one of these
whistleblowers
and alleging that Hunter was paying
prostitutes with company money and then
writing it off I mean you actually have
red flags you even have smoking guns
here when you look at what's on the
laptop and there's there's not an
investigation then when there is an
investigation the lightest possible
charges right yeah thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time